If we now try to summarize what we have so far, we have a pile class and its got
operations. We can put a tree onto the pile. We can get a tree from the pile.
We can take a tree off of the pile. For the counter we have increment and
display. And for the tree class we have split and throw away.
Now, a minute ago we talked about throwing away from the pile,
and sometimes these things can go back and forth. For the moment we are going to
associate with the tree class. In our class model diagram we added a new
compartment at the bottom of the rectangle to hold the operations. In general,
we could also at this time list of
various arguments that go arguments to the operations, what their types are,
what is the type of the return value, or we could hold off that process later.
What we are trying to do is get a feel for what the elements of the problem are,
and how, how, how they are represented in terms of attributes, and then
what services the various the various classes can have in terms of operations.